(soothing violin music)
- [Woman] When I was growing up,
I spent a lot of time outside.
I would go on these adventures,
either in the local park
or even my front yard.
And I spent a lot of time
searching for four leaf clovers.
Science starts with observation,
being able to pay close
attention, and ask question.
That's the spark of science.
(soothing orchestral music)
Oh! Wait a minute, here's another one!
(mumbles)
(woman laughs)
That's usually a good sign.
I like to put traps where I
see a lot of four leaf clovers.
I'm Danielle N. Lee.
I'm a National Geographic
Emerging Explorer,
and I study nuisance rodents.
A nuisance or pest animal is any animal
that gives people a problem.
Rodents, like rats and mice,
have been a problem for humans
since the beginning of time.
They can cause a lot of disease,
so we wanna understand more about them
so that we can live
healthier, better lives.
I'm interested in
studying nuisance rodents
because I wanna understand
how these animals
successfully persist
despite how hard people
have tried to get rid of
them for hundreds of years.
So I study field mice across
an urban to rural gradient.
So that's looking from a big city,
all the way to a farm area,
to a more natural area
where there's more forest
and grasslands.
I'm trying to understand
the behavioral differences
of city mice and country mice.
(mousetrap clicking)
I like these small traps
because they carry well in your bag.
I open them up and they are ready to go.
And then when I find the perfect place
where I think mice may be,
It's just as easy as that to set them.
I come back just a couple hours later,
and I can catch a mouse
if they are out here.
(wooden fence creaks)
This is the urban part of my gradient,
here in the St. Louis metro area.
Here surrounded by buildings,
there are still a lot
of places for wildlife,
like nuisance rodents,
to find a perfect place to live
and make a living.
(playful music)
(birds singing)
(mumbles)
Oh yeah.
Smells like a mouse.
Once we catch the mice safely,
we removed him from the trap.
He's swaddled like a baby.
All right.
So we got another Peromyscus.
Definitely a male.
14.5 grams.
We weigh them.
Measure different parts of their body,
and then we individually
identify them with a tag.
This gives us a glimpse
into how animal communities
are using habitats in our area.
Understanding what makes city mouse
and country mouse the same and different
from one another is the
goal of my research.
And I'm interested in
differences that might
make them bolder and risk
coming into your house
as opposed to staying outside.
(gentle acoustic guitar music)
I think understanding them better
is how we do better at living around them.
So I'll release her back
to where she came from,
and if I catch her again in the same place
then I know that this is
roughly where she's made a home.
I think its important to
do science close to home.
Its so many questions
that we still don't know,
and so many answers that we've yet to find
about the wildlife that lives
right outside of our door.
There are living
laboratories all around us.
And you can get started now.
There she goes,
back home.
(happy acoustic guitar music)